the light is satisfied with all access
some legal issues to resolve the rest of
the news is good
agreed King Breanna now leads a puppet
kingdom thanks in no small part to our
newest members influence
yes well I'm no Martian but my limited
meta psychic ability does come in handy
to nudge people towards their own worst
impulses no need to be modest fee odd
your services are much appreciated now
I'm sure you're all wondering about my
recent trip to apocalypse darkside and i
rattled sabers at each other over our
mutual sense of betrayal where our
differences but managed to find common
ground and reconfirm our partnership of
course his search for the anti-life
equation continues so we must prepare
for keeping eyes on this halo she could
be the key to our final victory which
means we need a new leader one who was
consistently acted as the conscience of
the lead and although I'm not a member
I'd like to take the liberty of
nominating Black Lightning seconded all
current leaguers present and in favor
and aboard the javelin whoa whoa I don't
want this maybe not but we kind of need
you to take it
let's say you I don't have a vote
currently if I take this you're either
in or you out there's no half wait no
behind it seems crap if you take this
will fold Batman Inc back into the
league and the team on your terms
it's for the best
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody is Charlie this is gonna be my
Young Justice season 3 video for the
ending the end credits scene and what's
going on during season 4 I get a lot of
requests for Young Justice videos but
it's always hard to tell how many of you
guys are actually watching the show if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter-egg
videos there's gonna be so much crisis
on Infinite Earths
in Joker movie birds-of-prey stuff
happening in the next couple of weeks
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen Young Justice season 3 because
we'll be talking about everything it'll
also talk about all the season 4 teasers
they were renewed for season 4 so there
will be a season 4 probably starting in
January next year probably on the same
episode schedule that season 3 was on
but just going down the list top 10
style this season was all about the
light working with Darkseid to
manufacture metahumans and forced them
to serve as his private army in his war
to conquer the universe the
old-fashioned way going one planet at a
time but that's just a plan that he told
the light he's secretly double-crossing
them because he wants to learn the
secret of the anti-life equation which
will give him total control over the
universe there was this big plot at the
beginning of the season about the
Justice League breaking up Batman
quitting because the light through Lex
Luthor in the United Nations were
controlling the Justice League through
bureaucracy Lex Luthor technically
wasn't doing anything illegal enforcing
the Justice League to stop so he
prevented them from going around saving
people which is where the Young Justice
team came in so part of the thing this
season is they created three separate
covert ops teams the regular Justice
League which is sort of hamstrung the
old Young Justice team from a last
season that became the Young Justice
outsiders with a bunch of new characters
that popped up and then Batman put
together his own team of Batman
characters and called it Batman Inc
separately all those teams worked
independently as different cells to try
and stop Darkseid in the light in
dismantle their met a human trafficking
organization number eight next big WTF
is Black Lightning is named the new
leader of the Justice League
he'd been the one that was super opposed
to the way Batman was going about trying
to stop Darkseid in the light no more
secrets bring it back out of the open we
can't be lying to each other like this
Batman's rejoining the Justice League as
well as Nightwing and then all the
younger characters that were working
with Batman Inc are gonna fall
back into the Young Justice team next
big WTF number 7 the light and Vandal
Savage have also kind of got into a
shadow war with dark side in Apocalypse
both groups are now separately trying to
uncover the anti-life equation first
because they find out that dark side has
been double-crossing them so they get
really pissed off so they're gonna try
and double-cross him before he can
double-cross them we also learned that
violet is somehow the key to unlocking
the anti-life equation they explained
the reason why violet is so powerful is
because she was created when the living
soul of a mother box fused with the dead
human remains of a woman in markovia
they never fully explained how all of
her powers work because that's gonna
spill into season 4 like why is it that
she is the key what exactly about her in
her mother box physiology makes her the
key to spreading the anti-life equation
all over the universe 6 cyborg is the
other side of that equation he was
created when his father used an
apocalyptic father box to save his life
it took him all season but eventually he
was able to recalibrate all of his new
gods tech to become a regular comic book
cyborg most of the season the soul of
the father box within him was trying to
take over his mind 5 big WTF Metron of
the New Gods flying around in his Mobius
chair watching all these terrible things
happen all season told violent in
cyborgs that he thought of them as his
grandchildren since they were the
products of his creations the mother
boxes in the father boxes remember
mother boxes are New Gods tech their
souls are thought of as good father
boxes are Darkseid's copies of mother
boxes they're thought of as being more
controlling more dominating a little
more evil but he's sort of a passive
observer and all this like one of the
Watchers like he doesn't want to help
them out but he's fascinated by how all
this is unfolding I can't wait to see
what the both of you turn into no big
surprise but granny goodness wound up
being Darkseid's plant on earth the
whole season using VR goggles using
television stations Hollywood
entertainment to try and mind-control
everyone
that's the writers just doing a little
bit of commentary on modern culture like
you're being hypnotized by all these
video games and television shows they
kicked her ass by the end of the season
so that's why dark side is gonna be
torturing her for the next couple of
months but
for there was a very very long Wally
West wrap-up episode right at the end I
know you all have questions what's going
on is wally west ever coming back in
real life that whole sequence was just
about giving artemis some closure
because she never really got to say
goodbye to Wally before he's seemingly
quote-unquote died we have to say
seemingly die because we think he's dead
but we can't prove it Zatanna used her
magic to create a false reality that
allowed Artemis to live out a life of
simulation of a life with Wally West at
SuperSpeed no pun intended
they got married they had a baby she got
her closure all within about five
minutes and now she's in a new
relationship with Will Harper and
they're raising the baby yes I do think
that Wally West will eventually come
back in real life but just in time for
things to be maximum awkward between all
the characters still open a theory
crafting about how long they're gonna
sit on that before he actually comes
back but there was an episode where they
all hallucinate the older version of The
Young Justice team the classic team with
Wally West and that was also kind of
meant to give the characters and the
fans closure so I don't expect Wally to
come back right away because they gave
us all that Wally at the end of the
season three the big montage at the end
is just to show you all the newer
characters that were either created this
season or joined the team this season
are integrating with society in a
positive way all the metahumans created
by the light leading relatively happy
lives for the time being remember we're
getting a season four so shit's gonna
hit the fan again pretty quickly so all
of them chilling out hanging out in the
diner that's just temporary before
things go real crazy again the light is
now controlling geo force and implanting
suggestions in his head using this
psychic standing next to him they seize
the throne of markovia through him so
his sister Tara who was going full-blown
Teen Titans Judas contract with
Deathstroke on Beast Boy turns good but
thanks to the light in that telepath
near by her brother geo force the good
guy totally breaks bad killing their
uncle Superboy and Miss Martian are
still getting married that might go down
during season four at some point I don't
know how long they're gonna be engaged
but they're supposed to get married
sometime soon
Nightwing and Oracle have actually been
pretty rock steady all season no drama
between the two of them but number two
you're asking about the big teaser for
the
aegeon of superheroes at the end of the
episode when the camera is panning
around the diner you see this faceless
waitress walking around pouring coffee
for everyone you never see her face you
only see that she has a blonde ponytail
and then the camera zooms in on her ring
and it's a legion of super-heroes ring
and obviously it is just a big teaser
that they're gonna introduce the Legion
of super-heroes during season four
so season four will involve some time
travel usually the only reason why the
Legion would get involved is if someone
from the future like a villain comes
back into the past or if it's gone
darkest timeline in darkside is
successful in acquiring the anti-life
equation at some point in they're trying
to change the past but number one the
actual end credits scene is just a big
long-running Lobo joke that's been going
on since almost the beginning of the
season there were a lot of you after
that Lobo episode when he got his finger
chopped off that are like hey wait a
minute is that gonna grow into another
version of Lobo well turns out you were
right it totally grew into another Lobo
the camera just sits there waiting on
his bare ass for him to turn around
break the fourth wall staring into
camera like I can't wait to cause all
this mayhem in the big rug pool moment
is that the original Lobo who's still
alive steps on him because there can be
only one Lobo and technically his powers
don't work like that
but Lobo can regenerate his entire body
from a single drop of blood so we just
meant to be a funny Lobo joke won't have
much bearing on next season the Legion
of super-heroes ring is the actual
teaser for season 4 but like I said the
probably premiere season for either in
January or early next year sometime if
you do have any big questions about what
happened during season 3 of the
characters or what's going on with
season 4 just leave those questions in
the comments and even though I just
posted a birds-of-prey trailer video I
think we're gonna get a longer one
sometime in the next couple of days and
we have the Joker movie coming out
really soon too and if your big watchmen
fan I will be doing HBO Watchmen episode
videos but that's not gonna premiere til
later in October so there'll be more
trailers for that role soon
congratulations kid fury you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here to watch that Harley Quinn
birds-of-prey trailer and click here for
my non-spoilery Joker movie review
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you